alors bonjour ma planète bienvenue à
l'émission tam-tam canada bien connu
aussi sous son nouveau nom qui s'appelle
toute la planète en parle ici autour
natal nous avons bien sûr nos
coéquipiers de cette semaine et on va se
tourner vers la planète pour la saluer
pour la remercier
on va encore aujourd'hui parler d'une
question très importante au plan de la
santé vous allez le voir la dernière
fois qu'on l'a fait c'était il ya deux
semaines on a établi des records de cap
des côtes n'est ce pas alors nous jamais
deux sans trois on va le faire à nouveau
aujourd'hui autour de la table paloma
martinez bonjour pas le vin ge stéphane
de la section latino-américaine je dis
ça parce que cette semaine on prête ses
services à cet autre section normalement
à travailler avec nous et puis de la
section anglaise de radio canada
international
bonjour marc et puis marie claude simard
bien connu dans le monde et simard au
québec c'est un nom de famille très
connue identifie à quelques stars il la
dette
bonjour tout le monde et puis les ogm
gimeno de la section latino-américaine
webmestre bonjour bonjour monsieur
alors merci beaucoup d'être là
aujourd'hui vous connaissez la tradition
cinq images vidéo on vous présente vous
me dites c'est quoi le sujet cette
semaine et les nous internautes
participent et s'amuse avec moi même
maman porte deviner le sujet première
image
bisous bisous aux opérations
chirurgicales coeur ça s'annonce mal
5e l'image devrait vous aider encore
peau des hommes recyclables et la
réponse oui on ajouté
j'allais ajouter les images de garçons
pour comment s'appelle attention d'être
pistonné ensuite ici j'en parle pas mais
c'était pour quelqu'un qui est pas ou
aujourd'hui avec nous malheureusement
alors c'est ça don d'organes sujet très
sérieux
il ya des bonnes nouvelles mauvaises
nouvelles d'accord on va s'intéresser
aux deux aujourd'hui nombre de donneurs
est en augmentation constante au canada
une hausse qui se traduit aussi par une
baisse du nombre de personnes sur la
liste de gens qui ont besoin d'organes
on disait pas ça il ya peut-être dix ans
ça c'est nouveau
les québécois aussi en masse disent oui
au don d'organes sur les sur les permis
conduire même chose au canada 4 ce
québécois sur dix ont déjà signé un
accord en ce sens est au québec vous
avez encore important un peu plus de 800
personnes qui sont en attente d'un don
d'organe
malgré tout les parieurs ont fait 800
personnes c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes je pense que les dernières six
était que tout près de 250 étaient
décédés il y à l'interné parce qu'on
attendait qu'on n'a pas reçu à temps
aujourd'hui je vais vous demander c'est
la question première question notre jeu
questionnaire et on va aujourd'hui
vérifier l'étendue de notre de nos
connaissances limitées
je veux dire c'est très bon général
pendant ces questions là c'est la
première manche de notre jeu que siens
de la grosse boule c'est bon pour
combien de points jamais après les
habitués des habitués le savent c'est 20
points alors voici vous nous lisez la
question marie-claude qu'elle est
l'organe plus transplantés transplantés
au canada avec 1731 chirurgie en 2016
paloma rhin je suis d'accord pourquoi
mais parce que c'est la bonne réponse
pour moi je dire le foie pourquoi la
commission
koné les autrichiens ses côtes d'ici là
je vais faire comme elle il ya deux fois
plus d'arrêts je sais pas si tu sais que
vous donnez raison ma mais vous avez la
bonne réponse vous et paloma 20 points
chacun sait le rhin et pour au niveau
des détails si ça vous intéresse
c'est dans 57% des cas c'est énorme
on va voir d'autres c'est qu'au fil des
missions de ne pas tout en même temps
bien sûr on garde un peu de points voilà
je vous propose c'est une histoire parce
qu'on a toujours un spécialiste à cette
émission
encore une fois c'est un des grands
spécialistes sur cette question au
canada je vous propose d'abord cette
histoire après deux chambres parce que
ces histoires d'organes ce sont des
personnes notamment tout ce sont des
gens sont pas que des uns des morceaux
des ccc ccc une réalité que l'on vit pas
souvent mais à trop souvent voici
l'histoire d'une jeune femme s'était en
regardez bien ces images ça dure une
minute 45 secondes reportage de radio
canada julie gagnon une jeune fille oise
est à ces femmes
une visite pour oublier la bataille
contre une maladie qui grandit c'est dit
c'est parce que on en voit beaucoup de
changements il n'en a pas toujours été
ainsi
il y a eu les jours meilleurs une
passion pour la musique
le choix de vivre à fond chaque jour
malgré la fibrose kystique
chacun sa personnalité mais julie étonné
parce que maman forte nous impressionne
tous elle est une vraie battante
sauf que le temps commence à manquer
malgré tout son courage
à moins d'une transplantation pulmonaire
julie est condamné cette transplantation
pulmonaire mais sa vie est très écourtée
heureusement que nous quitter au cours
des prochaines semaines tellement sa
maladie et à ben ainslie
mais voilà que l'histoire ce site
l'appui de l'animatrice véronique
cloutier sur les médias sociaux et que
les témoignages de sympathie commencent
à affluer
on reçoit des beaux messages de partout
dans le monde des gens qu'on veut
sensibiliser une carte de don d'organes
dans le dos peut-être le donneur qui
peut tout changer pour julie je crois
vraiment alors voilà si vous avez
entendu le téléphone sonne et c'était
pas dans le reportage c'était le
téléphone de notre invité spécial cette
semaine sur skype
on sera avec lui dans un instant ou deux
vous vous demandiez n'est ce pas comment
cette histoire at elle terminé c'était
en 2015 cette jeune femme dans la ville
de québec on en a beaucoup parlé comment
ça s'est terminé
les médias ont abondamment parlé ça
s'est bien terminé
c'est une question j'ai besoin d'une
affirmation ça s'est très bien terminée
initialement elle a reçu finalement cinq
greffes de poumons ce qui est une
opération plutôt rare sauf qu'elle est
décédée au mois de janvier de l'an
dernier près de 2 en un peu plus de deux
ans après avoir reçu cette greffe elle
était retournée au travail il était
plein d'énergie il ya eu semble-t-il un
problème peut-être de rejet la barre de
ses poumons
donc une fois qu'on reçoit l'organe ce
n'est pas nécessairement garnier il ya
des encore des des obstacles à vous de
ventes soit une fois avec une grève
comme ça il faut prendre des médicaments
le restant de la vie exactement écoutez
aucun d'entre nous n'est spécialistes
c'est le temps de se tourner vers celui
qui aura réponse à nos questions
simple et compliqué à la fois alors il
s'agit du dr pierre marsolais directeur
du centre de prélèvement d'organes de
l'hôpital du sacré-coeur à montréal
bonjour docteur marsolais bonjour tu
mens désolé pour le téléphone j'avais
pensé a débranché mon téléphone s'il
aime et je n'ai pas pensé à l'hôtel
ça fait partie de la vie j'espère que
c'était pas un appel urgent est ce qu'on
vous réveille la nuit des fois parce que
vous êtes dans un domaine de ce très
sensible oui tout à fait oui oui on a
fait comme la plupart des médecins qui
font des gammes d'euros soit 7 ans et on
est entraîné à seuil pour nous la nuit
le jour ça fait plus de différence
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à devenir un
spécialiste des dons d'organes
en fait j'ai pas exposition j'ai ma
spécialité devancé la médecine et en
soins intensifs et rapidement dans les
années 80 j'ai compris je l'aurais les
soins intensifs les soins de ou
intensifs
donc les personnes qui avaient des
lésions cérébrales gare et
malheureusement il ya des gens qui
décèdent
on doit annoncer des décès et si j'ai
rapidement compris que d'offrir l'option
du don d'organes à une famille était une
source de soulagement très important
d'ailleurs c'est la principale raison
pour laquelle moi a fait même à dix
matches de motivation à moi oui les dons
d'organes profite aux receveurs
d'organes mais ça profite aussi aux
familles de donneurs est donc cette
forme de soulagement l'eau qui en même
temps m'arrêter et me réconforte moi de
pouvoir soulager ces femmes explique
essayons de montrer à notre auditoire
qui une voie internationale qui
aimeraient comprendre la place du canada
dans sa par rapport à cet enjeu là j'ai
lu des articles indiquant que c'est
l'espagne qui est l'art korman dans le
monde au niveau du don d'organes un
petit pays qui est plus pauvre que le
canada nous sommes à la traîne des états
unis où s constitue mondialement je
reconnais probablement dans le milieu de
la classe on peut faire nettement mieux
pour donner une idée la portugal la
croatie l'espagne l'autriche la belgique
la finlande font mieux que le canada on
est probablement 10e ou 11e
les études du collège des médecins ont
démontré qu'au canada au canada et au
québec loi incluant pionnat de là on
peut faire deux fois mieux deux fois
mieux parce qu'on fait de 20 à 22
données par la population mais notre
potentiel ordonna cadavérique mort
cérébrale c'est plus de 40 alors on fait
la moitié de ce qui est possible de
faire le jeu ne parle que d'une
catégorie de donneurs cadavériques qui
donne à mort cérébrale il existe une
autre catégorie des données auprès des
cercles de soutien toi qui de plus de 40
également donc le vrai potentiel au
canada c'est plus de 80 donneurs par
million
on avait bien aussi moi j'ai découvert
sans fin cette semaine en faisant des
recherches je m'étais jamais vraiment
revenu sur le sens que des donneurs
vivants bien sûr qu'ils aient des
donneurs vivants et c'est une catégorie
importante mais qui est en déclin
j'ai regardé les statistiques un rapport
canadien là dessus c'est un petit peu
étonnant par rapport au fait que en fait
plus en plus de publicités à chaque
année par rapport au don d'organes puis
il ya un déclin de ce côté là alors que
la médecine les provinces
oui d'écouter le déclin est pas aussi
important parce que c'est j'ai regardé
et j'ai compris dès 2006 et 2010 ça
c'est un point par million
il ya un léger déclin effectivement il
ya eu beaucoup de progrès à faire
beaucoup surtout au québec trawick et au
québec ont été longtemps les champions
canadiens dont cadavérique
mais les derniers de classe a dont
vivent et là on commence on commence à
s'améliorer au québec en don vivant il
ya beaucoup de chemin à faire ce côté là
et moi j'ai bon espoir que le don le don
vivant va garder le cap
vous restez par femme j'ai une
statistique a montré à l'antenne et
ensuite mes collègues vont participer à
la conversation
c'est
la vidéo de 0,4 c'est très court et ça
montre les opérations des
transplantations les plus fréquentes et
j'ai été surpris en voyant le cas de la
jeune femme qui recevait un
transportation des poumons
la liste d'attentes ses 330 jours mais
le quand on arrive au pancréas c'est
1689 jours c'est des écarts tout à fait
incroyable pourquoi une telle différence
par rapport à un type d'organes le power
pack réagirait deux principes du raisons
principales premièrement en grève des
progrès ans a déjà qu'ils sont
diabétiques et les abbés tic dans le
fond sont affligés d'une maladie qui est
le diabète pour laquelle on doit prendre
des médicaments
l'insuline alors si je vous greffe un
pancréas je vais vous soulagé de votre
diabète mais je vais vous donner une
autre maladie c'est-à-dire le rejet donc
pour laquelle je ris à prendre des
médicaments anti-rejets donc rappeler
c'est un problème par un autre n'est pas
nécessairement toujours avantageux on va
greffer cela plus plus plus souvent des
spas créances à des gens qui auront
besoin aussi d'un deuxième organe
exemple les diabétiques souvent vont
tomber en instance rénale donc auront
besoin d'un rein donc de toutes façons
auront besoin d'être greffés alors tant
qu'à greffer tout ce biais des soulagés
de leur visage est en même temps donc ce
sera rien pancréas
quand les débats sont très mal contrôlée
on va d'abord on va transporter des
dépôts créances et des diabétiques
seulement que le pack realmac alors
cibler les diabétiques les plus
compliqués les plus difficiles à gérer
pour donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ya moins de greffe de pancréas que
vous les greffes de peau grasse
ça prend plus de temps donc si celle-là
on va cibler les receveurs pour pour que
l'aide d'un traitement la dira qu'il
soit approprié pour la qualité de vie
aussi anodin et comme l'occasion c'est
qu'elle elle n'est pas grasse est
relativement récente aussi beaucoup plus
récent que les autres les autres types
d'écrire parce qu'avant on prétendait
que j'ai fais un pancréas ont rappelé un
problème je me demandais comment on peut
faire pour faire mieux parce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure docteur qu'on
pourrait donner de faire la donation de
les dons d'organes deux fois plus que ce
qu'on fait actuellement comment on fait
comment on ferait sa commande pourrait
atteindre cet objectif là c'est là la
vraie question c'est très tu as raison
pour laquelle on n'y arrive pas c'est
que c'était très compliqué c'est que la
plupart des spécialistes
ça que c'est multifactoriel
mais les gens à la population les
décideurs vont cibler un problème par
exemple le concernant présumés on voit
cela tous les envois des manifestations
des pétitions des gens qui vont
prétendre avec un consentement présumé
ça règlerait tous les problèmes je peux
vous dire que le consentement présumé
n'est pas la solution au problème
même dans des pays où il ya consentement
présumé exemple en espagne on prétend
que le consentement présumé nu au
processus de don d'organes il ya des
endroits exemple au brésil on a installé
le conjoint vous me voyez fallu il a
fallu lui cette loi là parce que on
s'apercevait que ça nuisait au don
d'organes
comment on peut faire mieux plusieurs
facteurs premièrement le don d'organes
c'est très éprouvant pour les
professionnels et c'est très compliqué
sur les études partout dans le monde
en pologne en france en suède les études
démontrent que pour les professionnels
le don d'organes c'est plus compliqué
que faire décidé que les patients
habituel de soins intensifs
pourquoi parce qu'on a affaire à des
gens qui sont décédés donc et des
charges émotionnelles etc sont très
importantes
on doit raconter des familles et les
professionnels sont tristes quand ils
font sur situe un centime à l'échec
puis on sait pas en patinant sur
inscription triste avec la famille les
bars les personnes à mort cérébrale sont
très instables
donc il ya le défi émotionnel éthique
morale il ya les défis médicale
c'est-à-dire d'arriver à stabiliser les
organes d'une personne dont le cerveau
ne fonctionne plus dans celui des filles
le troisième défi les administratifs
là vous allez occuper un lit de soins
intensifs avec des ressources très
importantes pour un patient entre
guillemets dans la plupart la plupart
des gens vous dis ben oui mais la pierre
je veux accuser tout perso cela pour un
patient qui est mort à ce qu'on peut
s'occuper des vivants parce qu'on est si
on ne met pas dans la balance que cette
personne-là décédé pourrait en trouver
quatre cinq six sept autres dans
d'autres dispositions
donc il faut voir plus loin que ça
l'administrateur qui ne s'occupe que de
la gestion de son propre hôpital lui il
voit son propre budget puis dans le fond
les lyssoises et ainsi soulager ailleurs
n'est pas sa préoccupation
donc il faut arriver donc ce après cette
conscience sociale administrative sa
princesse
ce que ce courage moral éthique qui
émotionnel et ça prend aussi la volonté
de vous
plus la capacité de stabiliser ces
patients sont très instables le choix
des lombes répond que l'ama nature à
écouter vous avez mis le doigt sur
quelque chose dans votre nom réponse
c'est que c'est un long processus
impliquant beaucoup de gens c'est
pancanadien bien souvent des cuivres -
scène là où vous pouvez me montrer là
vous me décrire au haut à tout le monde
à quel point ça peut devenir extrêmement
compliqué au niveau des équipes qui
viennent chercher les organes la machine
lesca les gens souvent ne réalisent pas
c'est que derrière un don d'organes il
ya une immense machine
je donne un exemple si un donneur dans
un hôpital exemple en périphérie de
montréal et que la famille souhaite
procéder au don d'organes permet à
partir du moment où vous dites oui au
don d'organes en moyenne il ya trente
six heures en moyenne des fois ci plus
longue soit 36 heures entre le moment où
vous dites oui et le prélèvement
d'organes ce 36e là il doit y avoir
l'investigation et l'attribution des
échographies chacun des organes par
foyer des biopsies des scans les
bronchoscopies des coronarographies
investi chacun des hommes se sourient
qui sont corrects
il faut trouver les receveurs
compatibles et parfois il ya un receveur
à toronto hier soir à edmonton bien le
sauveur à québec
imaginez la personne bilingue l'hôpital
périphérie doit être transféré dans un
centre de prélèvement d'organes exemple
comme à l'hôpital du sacré coeur de
montréal et a sacré coeur où dans les
autres hôpitaux où ils se font des
prélèvements il ya des infirmiers aspect
saisie qui vont prendre soin des
familles de donneurs
pour l'heure les soutenir tout au long
du processus parce que n importe quoi
vous pourriez dire d'acteurs vous perdez
votre fille par exemple
dr on n'est plus capables là c'est trop
souvent on va arrêter alors on perd tout
on peut perdre les organes ils reçoivent
à perdre est l'organe des gens qui vont
mourir sur les attend dans le faux
souvenirs les familles là vous êtes dans
l'autre hôpital on doit faire toute sa
qualification cette attribution viendra
de toronto un avion pour venir patrick
est de toronto viennent prévu librement
l'équipe de québec viennent par avion
prélever le cas et l'équipe de edmonton
vient pour chercher le pancréas et il
est dit choqué par exemple de montréal
gontran les reins et le foie
dans une salle d'opération pour un
prélèvement d'organes j'ai déjà compté
23 personnes vingt-trois personnes dans
une salle
alors quand on voit un donà tranquille
danger lyssoises et asif on imagine poc
l'emploi à partir du point à
jusqu'à destination parce que dans ces
hôpitaux là à toronto à québec edmonton
les blocs opératoires sont bloqués parce
que 4 personnes 4 il surgit au maroc les
poumons pour opposer mais maintenant on
prend deux numéros qu'on attend on
attend d'octobre et le bloc opératoire
donc tout est bloqué partout incluant
des équipages d'avions incluant des
anesthésistes design thérapeute à
distance c'est encore les 22 personnes
dame dans ma salle d'opération il y a il
ya énormément de gens en amont et en
aval c'est extrêmement compliqué les
gens qui font cette coordination là
c'est les organistes de coordination
exemple au québec cet instant québec en
ontario site choisi un ghetto vous
parlez de transports québec pendant que
marc va vous poser une question on va
passer des images filmées par transports
québec dans lequel on vous avait été
impliqué on a retiré votre image
on a fait un petit montage et on a
montré ces gens auxquels on est venus en
aide donc c'est des histoires qui se
terminent bien on laisse filer
pendant que on écoute le docteur harcelé
et montgomery
alors c'est une question de hauteur est
il un âge
après lesquels ça vaut plus le pen
vraiment d'enlever les organes du jeune
homme de 65 ans par exemple est ce
qu'elle est le choeur les grains et crs
sont trop disons usées est ce qu'on des
transferts de transplantation de rein
d'une personne de 65 ans dans une jeune
de 20 ans par exemple ça c'est une
excellente question
je suis bien content que vous la poésie
parce que je vais vous surprendre
première réponse il n'ya pas de limite
d'âge pour répondre ensuite c'est que
l'on va on va toujours à attribuer les
organes à la personne n'avait plus
approprié exemple des coeurs on va
tenter des cas jusqu'à squatter dix ans
mais juste pour vous surprendre parce
que c'est une exotique les beaucoup le
donneur le plus âgé au canada avait 88
ans c'était un fois et on a fait une
émission à la radio l'année dernière
avec que j'ai fait une émission à
l'année dernière qu'une jeune femme
la jeune femme avait 19 ans ce québécois
cdh et en ontario elle avait perdu
conscience dans un parc un pass à loos
d'or étendu sur le bâtard qui a crû de 9
1 elle était à l'hépatite fulminante
elle a besoin d'un fois le besoin des
fois tout de suite
y'a pas d'appareil qui remplace la
fonction d'un fois malheureusement n'y
avait pas de donneur deux fois la jeune
femme était pour mourir le souhaitent
fois que se présente et c'est un
monsieur 88 ans dont la famille a eu le
courage de 10
oui s'il vous plaît si ça peut sauver
quelqu'un peut-être le lait chaud j
avais l'intention de prendre ce fois
l'autre sont temporaires le temps de la
lui permet de survivre en attendant
avoir une autre fois ça fait 15 ans
hélas le même foie et le main et le mari
la personne qui le trouvaient dans le
parc et elle a des enfants
alors c'est un fois que 103 voilà
quelque chose non réponse encore pour
répondre autrement dit jamais jamais
dites vous que vous ne devez plus donner
vos organes pas ce que voulait pas nuire
aux saveurs à cause de votre âge parce
que voyez vous si cette famille-là avait
dit ça à 88 ans non non non il est tôt
il est trop bu laisser tranquille y en a
c'est fait
oui une question vous savez dit tout à
l'heure dans une de vos longue et
prononcée j'ai bien retenu c'est ce que
dire qu'on est disposé à donner nos
organes sains et peut nuire en fait les
dons d'organes pourquoi cette réalité là
c'est cela des consentements ouï dire
que vous voulez donner votre rayon sa
nuit pas mais le consentement présumé le
consentement présumé cdi registre où
vous êtes en donnant par défaut
c'est-à-dire exemple où tout le monde
est un exemple en espagne tout le monde
et d'honneur à moins que vous signifier
votre volonté de ne pas être de ma cage
comme au canada c'est contraire c'est
concerne explicite se dit vous êtes
donna parce que vous avez exprimé votre
volonté de le faire mais ce consentement
présumé là n'est pas un avantage parce
que toujours on demandera la famille
mais si consentement présumé est ce que
vous acceptez le don d'organes la
famille dit non c'est non que ce soit
résumé ou explicite dans tous les pays
on fait toujours la demande mis la loi
vous oblige pas de demander la
permission à la famille si moi j'ai dit
oui je serai je suis d'accord avec les
données mais maison quand est-ce que je
vais vendre quelque chose ou pas ne
m'oblige pas mais je vais le faire quand
même
imaginez vous perdez votre fille de 18
ans l'homme faisait le docteur vous est
effondré docteur il n'est pas question
que vous touchez à ma fille j'ai comme
savez comme un lion qui veut défendre sa
fille il ya pas un médecin ya pas un
professionnel qui va dire monsieur
parent vous avez pas un mot à dire de
toute façon j'ai droit des propres on
n'est pas des décrocheurs on se fait
donner il ya personne qui voit sa corde
non ça c'est pourquoi ils disent culte
en deux quand vous signez la carte comme
quoi vous êtes d'honneur d'expliquer la
situation à la famille et les proches
pour que ces situations n'arrive pas ou
n'est ce pas c'est la chose la plus
importante
puis à porter encore que 6 à 15 contre
saissac est important et le manifester
au registre est important le dire à
votre ami parce que c'est eux qui vont
souffrir votre perte et c'est eux qui
devront avoir le courage de passer à
travers tout ça donc vous devez leur
donner cette force là de dire écoutez
même si ça prend 36 48 heures sur un
respirateur
je souhaite sauver des gens s'il vous
plaît ne nous tairons pas net ne trompe
pas ce qui s'est passé c'est cela oui
mais je m'étais question peut-être sais
pas c'est pas très intelligent mais je
veux savoir c'est à la politique n'était
pas très intelligent et c'est si un
ennemi personnes enfants de 10-12 qui
dessert puis les parents et disent oui
est-ce que permettre un coeur d'une
enfant de 12 ans à une personne des
quatre taxes
en fait il ya eu deux n'ont qu'à 80 on
transporte pas des cas mais l'exemple
est bon quand même
c'est beaucoup plus une question des
dimensions et les transporteurs vont
s'assurer d'attribuer à la personne la
plus appropriée possible les coeurs
pédiatriques les jeunes car sont
tellement rares que souvent c'est le cas
en fait c'est toujours le contraire
c'est des querelles de personnes
beaucoup plus âgées qui vont être
transportés à des enfants parce que des
données pédiatriques
heureusement et malheureusement même
temps sont rares parce que les mort
cérébrale chez les enfants sont grands
mais lorsqu'il or ce qu'ils y en a qui
est souvent m'a fait du mal heureusement
il ya des enfants qui meurent sur des
listes d'attentes parce que faute de
coeur alors en fonction de la corpulence
du donneur d organes vont être attribués
à des offres souvent les enfants
une dernière questionna donna de 20 ans
peut être attribuée à quelqu'un vous
nous avez bien expliquer la complexité
de tout le processus et puis tout les
obstacles qu un médecin que les familles
rencontrent dans le processus mais vous
qu'est-ce que vous jugez qui serait le
plus important la démarche la plus
importante pour vraiment il ya une
amélioration du don d'organes au canada
moi ce sur quoi je travaille depuis le
début loge mais le maximum de mes
énergies
c'est de sensibiliser les professionnels
à mon avis le levier plusieurs plusieurs
facteurs limitants on perd un
pourcentage à chacun des chacun des
maillons faibles à mon sens là où on
pourrait gagner le plus c'est de
sensibiliser nos professionnels de la
santé
identifiez approcher et ça vous
rapprochez stabiliser les donneurs
d'organes et approcher les familles on
identifie avec nos tripes à la moitié
des donneurs et pourquoi parce que ou
bien le professionnel ne sais pas qui
leur donne un potentiel devant lui ou
bien il l'a pas puis ça s'est déshabillé
de la littérature là dessus il ne
s'affole le courage la capacité
d'approché une famille pour leur propose
cette option d'accord merci beaucoup
d'être venu aujourd'hui nous parler de
ça moi c'est mon contact le plus
approfondie par rapport à cette réalité
là je suis sûr que ceux qui se trouvent
de l'autre côté la caméra ce sera aussi
pour une occasion d'en apprendre
beaucoup plus qu'à trois ou quatre
minutes truc de d'entrevue à télévision
le web est fantastique par rapport à ça
merci beaucoup dr marsolais
alors c'était le dr pierre marsolais
directeur du centre de prélèvement
d'organes l'hôpital du sacré coeur je
vous le répète c'est le spécialiste au
québec sur ces questions là maintenant
on est prêt pour le jeu de la grosse
boule
ouais je voulais pas mettre au défi vos
connaissances pendant qu'il était encore
là sinon se révéla onze national c'est
normal il est encore là d'accord alors
voici deuxième manche c'est bon pour
combien de points et redemander à
leonardo nous lire la question il a si
l'une est aujourd'hui une des rares qui
décèdent au canada peut sauver la vie
des combien de personnes malades alors
d'honneur qu'il peut sauver la vie à
combien de personnes 7 7
vous pensez que c'est certain chips en
six mois je sois d'accord avec ça c'est
un bon fond de sa cage entendu neuf
donneurs vivants ou non
non mais tu avais des deux catégories
dehors c'est à dire ceux qui sont
cadavérique oui on peut être vivant mort
cérébrale c 'est donc je comprends pas
pourquoi vous riez vraiment sur un sur
sept
j'ai bien sûr sur neuf georges
officielle n'est encore figé s'est dit
plus que ça 15 pourquoi pas on parle de
sauver la vie donc si c'est pour venir
en aide vous auriez peut-être la bonne
réponse 15 facilement il ya des tissus
en prélève des tissus des tendons on
prêt après beaucoup de petits deux
petits morceaux
mais au niveau des organes n'avait pas
15 organe ce que je sache pu mettre de
la vie eux de sa vie à dieu
jamais à cours de biologie aux primaires
c'est essentiel alors ces huit 8
personnes
c'est qu'ils étaient les plus proches
mais c'est toi nous trois on peut peut
donner deux poumons donc on sauve des
vies voyez on divise la nive à ce niveau
là voilà pour le calcul alors c'est
combien vous combien peu 30 points pour
qui déjà moi j'ai dit et 7j 7 7
donc tant pointeront points 30 points il
n'y a pas une bonne réponse et puis
voilà donc ça fait ça fait cinquante 30
et 50
faut juste lui c'est parce que au début
mais j'ai laissé ma qué mac
alors c'est quoi le score ciani marc 50
d'accord
léo 30 marie-claude 0 paloma 5 a très
bien fait bien de ce dossier c'est comme
la santé vaut mieux vous monsieur ses
propres affaires que des médecins faire
les choses alors voilà écouté et j'ai
une belle nouvelle pour vous vous
rappelez notre invité donc dr marsolais
il était à la télévision d'une émission
qui a un peu comme une autre formule
s'appelle tout le monde en parle mieux
c'est tout athlète en parle c'était en
2009 le voici le voilà avec un patient
donné le reconnaître il est 1er plan le
quotidien et voici un extrait précisant
lui implanter un stimulateur
défibrillateur il a été mis sur liste
d'attenté pour une greffe de coeur à 32
ans
alors il ya trente trois ans
quatre enfants
après trois semaines de soins intensifs
et messi ne peut plus sauver
mon papa faisait noir qui l'a sauvé
[Musique]
la moto s'est levé comment vous avez su
que vous aviez des problèmes de cas ma
soeur est décédée avait 18 en allant
faire son jogging alors c'est pas normal
pions investi toute la famille et puis
trois mois plus tard dont je me ramasse
à l'institut de cardiologie en faisant
expliquer c'est quoi une cardiopathie
hypertrophique puis que un jour j'avais
besoin d'une greffe cardiaque et vous
aviez 13 ans à l'époque - est-ce que
vous avez pris ça comme une condamnation
devant je pense qu'à 13 ans j'ai jamais
été conscient de l'importance de toi de
te faire dire qu'à 19 ans en passe ainsi
de points car vraiment tu vas être
mangés jamais tu es conscient vraiment
de tout sur le meilleur je veux aucun
plan de carrière avant 19 ans parce que
pour moi je vais mourir à 10 à 19 ans
j'ai pas besoin d'étudier gens mourir à
19 comment se prépare puisque
logiquement recevoir un nouveau cas côté
à ma connaissance c'est encore aucun
manuel du parfait petit greffé il
voulait pas le degré et je porte un
poids car ailleurs rien je pense c'est
juste d'y aller avec la réalité que oui
demain et peut-être je vais mourir
et oui demain peut-être que je survive
et j'ai répondu 5 enfin à ce moment là
j'en avais cap marie leblanc ma femme
c'est de se tenir à ces bourrique son
lot puis d'une référence de dire j'ai
pas le droit de lâcher peu importe y
arrive j'ai pas le droit d'abandonner
peut-être qu'un jour ça va arriver même
si une fatalité qui est là qui toujours
pour un auditoire
c'était alors là c'était sylvain bédard
a greffé du coeur en 2009 et à
l'arrière-plan ya paix vous dans la vie
que vous l'avez reconnu oui le docteur
plus jeunes comme nous tous d'ailleurs
jeunes question mais je jubilais la peau
c'est fait
six mois je reçois un cas
puis dans trois ans j'aime dans une
accident puis mon corps il était intact
est-ce que je peux les données en cas je
m'imagine que oui pourquoi pas subi
autant de nîmes sont rien sans car c'est
sûr j'ai pas question pour vous la
question tu aimes tant canada il ya on a
posé la question il ya une personne qui
a répondu cette semaine on va regarder
c'est quoi la question m'a demandé ma
musique la question pour nous advenant
le cas où moulié accidentellement
seriez vous à l'aise ou non avec l'idée
de faire don de vos organes
je remercie marie claude simard qui a
fait l'image du coeur pleuvait pas fait
mais vous l'avez utilisé c'est bon on
sait très bien c'est très beau c'était
très représentatif c'est la question
qu'on a posé il ya une personne sur
facebook sur la personne qui s'est
prononcée pas un sujet facile c'est
parce que je fasse et je crois que tout
le monde se pose la même question quand
il faut il faut signer notre permis de
conduire ou même la carte d'assurance
maladie pour mon enfant quand on est
parent il faut la signer pour eux c'est
difficile
prends cette décision j'ai connu un
couple j'ai connu un couple qui qui dans
le mari était malade des reins
il lui fallait il lui fallait pas moins
un brin que c'est ça sa femme qui lui a
n'a d'autre qui lui a donné
c'était très difficile pour les deux
c'était vraiment
un événement dur à vivre sa durée
pendant plusieurs mois
c'est quelque chose ça va faire ça donc
une décision dure à prendre sur pour
deux personnes
c'est une 7e 6 h dans une vie c'est sur
mac c'est aussi cinq ans vous signez là
car pendant que vous êtes prête à donner
votre gang au kazoo c'est aussi comme
une réalité que ça peut arriver là vous
pouvez mourir ex temps tellement là
subitement 6 pers personne ne veut
mourir comme ça mais c'est comme signé
un sorte de compréhension que ça peut
arriver
le testament qu'on fait quand on inclut
quant aux 600 âmes à bas ces impulsions
connaught d'estomac et des gens qui
voudront jamais son destin
c'est effectivement c'est une
préparation à la mort c'est une
indication que ça va se terminer
peut-être mal il ya des gens ici au
canada qui commencent à acheter la paix
l'endroit ils vont être dépensés cd puis
au mexique et je le sais que je retiens
c'est moi c'est plus rare mais ici on
les achète avec beaucoup d'anticipation
on devrait signer aussi avec
l'anticipation de ces quotidiens
les gens qui donnent leur corps à la
science sa maison qui est mort il ya
deux ans d'un problème cardiaque qui a
donné son corps à la science une
histoire qui s'est terminée non je vous
donnerai d'autres d'état core en rente
ai mais il a servi ça aussi c'est un
très chaud très très très importants
jusqu'à lille et des médecins ont besoin
de l'herbe a besoin de voir qu'est ce
qui se passe et comment la fin c'était
là j'ai dû signer
avaient-elles quelques années pour
autoriser le prélèvement de membres et
pour la science
j'ai dû signer c'est ma mère qu'ils ont
coupé la jambe pour son direct puis il
était vraiment en salle d'opération puis
on est à quatre personnes qui m'ont
approché est ce que vous signez pauvres
c'est dur il pouvait pas prendre la
décision elle même non non il était
seuil était saoul à la médication il
pouvait pas les lui fallait deux
personnes de la famille puis je suis moi
j'étais le seul qui était là ces moments
là ils ont pas commencé
l'appellation jusqu'à que massa est
arrivé il ya signé aussi une bonne façon
de regarder la réalité en face et
d'imaginer nos proches comme nous on va
être des cdc pour leur simplifier la vie
en fait de tshing tt carte tu fais ton
testament parce que si tu facile de
faire l'autruche ne pas penser à ça mais
c'est vrai qu'il allait revenir au début
de l'émission vous avez dit que le
nombre de dons a augmenté au canada
derrière moi et ça c'est en partie à
cause de cet accident tragique drame
bolt en saskatchewan où le deuil
l'équipe d'or qui a été comme les
anéantit et les parents d'un fait don d
organes des jeunes jouaient dehors kiki
vainement le stand il était en bonne
forme donc le monde a pris conscience de
sa fille dit oui c'est une bonne idée et
pays beaucoup ont signé leur carte pour
disney a beaucoup aidés écoutez on est
prêts pour notre dernière question qui
va déterminer notre gagnant celui qui va
gagner notre estime cette semaine alors
voici la toile alors qui va lire la
question qui va se précipiter pour lui
la question mais l'éclat aux états unis
est la fin de mars à la fin mars
un soldat américain blessé en
afghanistan a reçu quel type de greffe
une première au monde
on entendu parler des premiers romans de
greffe du visage et a eu des grèves
donné aussi j'ai vu sa nouvelle maison
vous avez déjà oublié petit mémoire
mémoire très courte mois illégaux ça
s'appelle la greffe de cerveau est en
fait il ya un scientifique que je peux
dans quel pays je pense est en france
qui est juste passé vraiment en france
parce que c'est pas au canada il veut il
veut greffer la tête de quelqu'un est ce
que c'est une greffe
oui très délicat toutes les grèves sont
délicates
on va dire que je répondrai par oui ou
par non
moi je passe la main une grève demain
une grève comme je sais que c'est pas
vraiment un organe médite une greffe ce
soit ne sais pas je peux déjà vous dire
c'est pas la bonne réponse mais vous
allez me donner ce goncourt hier à
l'aube à la halle aux états unis à la
fin mars un soldat américain blessé en
afghanistan reçu quel type de greffe une
première au monde
est-ce que c'était une partie intime
parties intimes il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été ses tennis wii dès panis dit
la bénisse j'ai pas compris mais écoutez
jean pagé si vous le pensez
ils sont prêts à changer là
tout le reste j'ai lu simple c'était
très intéressant en fait les latics
c'est très intéressant parce qu'ils
allaient récupérer en fait les cieux la
ilaha illa il allait récupérer la
possibilité d'aider des relations ville
des relations sexuelles aussi mesquine
12e étape et un petit non non non ça
c'est une autre chose lui parle d'un
pénis du kgb compris maintenant votre
réponse à la passe qui la tête inventé
une histoire c'est une fausse nouvelle
garde un organe de la gorge
ahmed est l'organe commandes en espagnol
c'est la même chose qu'elle nommait en
italie c'est quelque chose mais sur
l'aspect gatinois garneau c'est votre
réponse à l'origine non mais vous savez
quoi je réponds sensible et paris claude
mais moi j'avais dit la même personne
c'est une grève du pénis et du scrotum
gagne et tout appui on espère qu'il va
retrouver ses fonctions sexuelles et
rugny n'ai rien dit
il n'y a pas de détails c'est ça la
chose très intime et c'est très sérieux
moi j'aimerais gagner peut-être parce
que je voulais pas le dire d'un mot mon
voisin est un ambulancier à raconter des
histoires
ça a quelque chose à voir les scrotum
ont gagné ses marques
il y avait cinq points sur points sur
100 ça ne s'est jamais vu non non mais
c'est pas vu depuis la semaine dernière
c'était complètement échoué
bah c'est fantastique merci beaucoup
d'avoir joué aujourd'hui et d'avoir
appris surtout parce que nous c'est le
sait le jeu à travers sinon c'est le
contraire c'est apprendre en jouant pas
l'inversé
sinon ce serait pas sérieux voilà merci
beaucoup et puis la semaine prochaine ne
serait pas la csu on peut déjà inscrits
renom dans la can à 0 pour le score qui
est toujours un grand agrandir le monde
merci beaucoup jack lemmon journaliste
très gentil merci infiniment d'avoir
accepté l'invitation aujourd'hui j'ai
demandé à la dernière minute à la
dernière-heure pas là dernier le dernier
marie claude simard à la semaine
prochaine ce genre on passe et puis
félicitations encore une fois on
l'applaudît
alors la caméra pour dire adieu à la
planète céline de l'es2 et deux au
revoir installé au pouvoir